[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Садова моя вишенька, ♪
♪ Туди-сюди похилилася ♪
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Через тин, та й на вулицю ♪
[російською] Нас називають горюнами.
[російською] Вважається, що горюни —
окрема нація, тому що ми живемо в горах.
[російською] Люди тут колись брали воду з одного колодязя,
який називається Мирський.
[російською] Людей називали горюнами.
[російською] Тому ми й назвали
свій колектив «Горюночка».
[російською] Пісні співаємо
своєю горюнською мовою.
[російською] У нас суміш російської, української
та білоруської мов.
[горюнською говіркою]
«Чего/каго», «йон», «пабьог»,  «пріньос»,
«нясєть», «вязєть», «єдіть».
[російською] Це у нас мова така,
і пісні у нас наші, горюнські.
[російською] Їх ніхто більше ніде не співає.
[російською] Де б ми не були, ми спілкуємося
своєю рідною мовою. Нам так легше.
[російською] Повторити наші горюнські
пісні дуже складно.
[російською] Як кажуть наші бабусі,
треба сім колін треба вивести.
[російською] Чи то сніг там, чи зима,
[російською] чи є бубен, чи немає,
[російською] на заслонці грали на рубелі
(старовинний аналог праски).
[російською] А співали...
Все село співало — всі до одного.
У хатах тчуть...
— Пряжу.
— Пряжу тчуть і співають.
[російською] Станок розіслали лиш...
[російською] Мама наша, сусіди...
— [російською] Збираються і тчуть пряжу.
— [російською] Тчуть пряжу, а ми на печі слухаємо все.
[російською] І собі співаємо.
[російською] Ану заспівайте «Сховалося сонце»,
хоч один куплетик.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Ой сховалося сонце, ♪
♪ сонце за віконце. ♪
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Ой та й за темне, ♪
♪ Ой та й за лісок. ♪
[російською] Наші бабусі й прабабусі, діди і прадіди
співали цю пісню.
[російською] От і ми, коли ще були молодими,
[російською] до нас додому приходили
десь зо п'ятнадцять бабусь в хату.
[російською] Сідають і співають.
А ми — на печі, то й я собі співаю.
[російською] Так і вивчили пісні.
[російською] Віддавна діти співали
з дорослими. Завжди.
[російською] От сидимо на печі,
нам подадуть картоплю-товченку...
[російською] Так, Раю?
З капустою поїмо і пісні співаємо.
— [російською] Часом і картоплі не було.
— [російською] Так, і картоплі не було.
— [російською] Підемо на поле…
— [російською] Складно було жили.
[російською] Гнилої картоплі назбираємо,
і маторжаники(коржики) пекли.
[російською] А то так, подавали картоплю до столу...
У кого вона була, ті й подавали.
[російською] А у кого не було, то...
Голод був.
[російською] Та й не у всіх була та картопля.
[російською] Ходили полем, збирали колоски і все робили,
[російською] а за ті колоски ще й судили.
[російською] Заспіваємо «Садову» пісню до кінця?
[російською] Яка та твоя «Садова»,
та зачекай із нею.
— [російською] Я вам не заважатиму?
— [російською] Ні, ні.
[російською] От знайшла собі пісню, Господи.
[російською] Хороша пісня.
Ну тоді «В лісі на горісі».
[російською] Гаразд.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Ой у лісі на горісі ♪
♪ соловей защебетав. ♪
[російською]
Ні, вище.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ А в іншому зеленому ♪
♪ козак дівчину вмовляв. ♪
[російською] Мабуть, з 1500-х чи 1600-х років
тут почалися поселення.
[російською] Той, хто більше працював,
мав більшу родину.
[російською] З тих часів ми тут і живемо.
— [російською] Світла ж тоді не було...
— [російською] Ще й в монастир ходили.
[російською] Світла тоді не було, то сім'ї багато.
[російською] Дітей багато зачинали, так.
— [російською] І по вісімнадцять дітей було.
— [російською] І по шістнадцять.
[російською] Мало дітей виживали.
[російською] Вже як світло з'явилося,
у мене було п'ятеро дітей.
[російською] П'ятеро дітей.
[російською] Зі світлом, так.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Садова моя вишенька, ♪
♪ Туди-сюди похилилася ♪
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Через тин, та й на вулицю. ♪
[російською] Добрий день, сестричко!
[російською] Я вже тут гуляла,
гуляла, гуляла.
[російською] Привіт!
[російською] Одягати не треба, сідай.
[російською] Нехай костиль там постоїть.
[російською] Просто одягали ось це,
[російською] голову вкривали наміткою
(жіночий головний убір).
[російською] Отак плахту носили.
[російською] Ось так підв'язували.
[російською] Спереду «здрастуй»,
а ззаду — «прощавай».
[російською] Ось такі лапті носили горюни.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Лапті мої ♪
♪  Чотири оборки, що ж ви мене, що ж... ♪
[російською] Як там далі у пісні?
[російською] Скажу вдома не ночую.
[російською] У Хведорки.
[російською] Це моя двоюрідна сестра.
[російською] Мені 77 років, їй — 94.
[російською] А ти танцювати вміла?
Танцювала?
[горюнською говіркою]
♪  Танцювала на току, збила взуття, ♪
♪ Залишилися на ногах панчохи та резинки. ♪
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Ой вечір вечоріє, ♪
[російською] Підтягни.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Колихається трава. ♪
[російською] Я всюди співала.
[російською] І на роботі — всюди.
[російською] У тебе є улюблена пісня?
[російською] У мене всі улюблені.
[російською] Пісні  — хоч лусни,
а їсти не проси, так?
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Красиві мої грона білі ♪
♪ Світлом сонця їх освіти. ♪
[російською] По-нашому викручувати,
так гекати й гокати, ніхто не буде.
[російською] Неподалік село Юр'єво,
[російською] вони наші пісні переймають,
[російською] але вони їх переінакшують.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ На широку долину ♪
♪ Йду-йду вулицею. ♪
[російською] Все, вистачить. Достатньо.
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Йду-йду вулицею. ♪
♪ Зупинюся послухати. ♪
[російською] Достатньо!
[горюнською говіркою]
♪ Зупинюся послухати ♪
♪ Чийого батька сварять. ♪